[Music]
oh
[Music]
i
[Music]
i know the reason why
the heart doesn't show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
hello
[Music]
you're always on the run now
[Music]
[Music]
before you stop it
[Music]
you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
i
oh
[Music]
all the voices in your head
[Music]
how's it going to
when you're married for the money
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
muscles
[Music]
my
is
[Music]
you can best believe that he's a bunch
of man
he likes to be the leader
[Music]
all right
all right
[Music]
uh
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's a special
i
oh
so fast
[Music]
[Music]
memories
[Applause]
and if i stay
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president
of the united states donald j
[Music]
the trump who died who gave that fight
to me
and i gladly stand up next to you
and defend her still today
because there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of
from sea texas shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time
[Music]
the men who died who gave that right to
me and i've had this end up
next to you and defend her still today
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Music]
to be an american
[Music]
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
be an american where at least i
know i'm free and i won't forget
the men who died who gave that light to
me
and
[Music]
[Music]
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's kind we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that life next to you
and defend her still today
[Music]
who
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot of people that's great
thank you very much
thank you very much that's a big group
of people
and this is on fast notice too thank you
[Applause]
well i just want to say hello minnesota
we love you minnesota you're great
great we're going to win minnesota
we're going to win minnesota because
they did nothing for minnesota except
close up that beautiful iron ore
territory they'd close it up with a pen
you remember that
one day you didn't have your jobs then i
came along and i opened it up so that's
pretty good
but i'm thrilled to be here with the
beautiful great hard-working people of
this incredible state you're really
hard-working american patriots that's
what you are and
a lot of people haven't been treated
right until i came along and we've done
a lot of work and a lot of good work
and you had your best year ever last
year the state had the best year you've
ever had
46 days from now we're going to win
minnesota and we're going to win
four more years in the white house
one of the most vital issues in this
election
is the subject of refugees you know it
you know it perhaps better than almost
anybody lots of luck
you having a good time with your
refugees that's good
we want to have omar he said omar that's
a beauty how the hell did she win the
election
how did she win
unbelievable every family in minnesota
needs to know
about sleepy joe biden's extreme plan
to flood your state with an influx of
refugees from somalia from other places
all over the planet
that's what's happened and you like omar
a lot don't you
[Applause]
biden has promised to 700 increase
in the manifesto with bernie right a 700
increase in the importation of refugees
from the most
dangerous places in the world including
yemen syria and somalia congratulations
minnesota
a 700 increase good luck minnesota enjoy
yourselves
because if i'm not here if i don't win i
don't know where i'm going to be but
maybe i'll come over to see mike
i'll come and see mike your state will
be overrun
and destroyed of biden and the radical
left win
that's what's going to happen i've been
watching it for years
they haven't treated you right they have
not treated minnesota right
[Applause]
thank you i'll tell you these hangers
are great
remember this it's a friendly protest
please remember this is not a rally
you're not allowed to have political
rallies of any kind you're not allowed
to go to church
you're not allowed to do anything the
only thing you're allowed to do is
run wild through the streets burn down
storefronts
blow up stores and kill people because
that's considered a protest and that
they allow you to have
you don't have to wear masks at protests
so i said you know we can't have a rally
the most we can have is 10 people
but why don't we just go into protest
because this is a protest
it's a protest against stupidity
[Music]
and speaking about stupidity sleepy joe
will turn minnesota into a refugee camp
think of it 700 increase so you're not
happy now
look at that guy over there he's not too
thrilled when he hears this
700 increase is what they have in the
manifesto now maybe they don't
honor it but i would say they'll go
substantially higher than that number
biden will overwhelm your children's
schools overcrowd their classrooms
and inundate your hospitals it'll happen
biden has even pledged to terminate our
travel ban
jihadist regions jihadist regions
they've already been doing that to you
haven't they opening the floodgates to
radical
islamic terrorists
my administration's keeping terrorists
extremists and criminals the hell out of
our country
we don't want them we got enough of them
we've got enough of them just today we
deported
as you know very well dozens of somali
nationals charged are convicted with
very grave crimes including rape assault
robbery terrorism
and murder of course these hardened
criminals are back in their
country where they can do all the
complaining they want
and your children are much safer as a
result thank you president trump thank
you
if it were up to biden and it's not it's
the people that surround him they are
seriously radical left democrats
and they're very dangerous and the
offenders are very dangerous
and they'd be running all over your
state only by voting for me
are you going to save i hate to say this
i did it with your iron ore
i did it with some other things and
uh i'll do it for you again
i'll do it for you again but if you vote
for me
i'm the difference and i'm the wall you
know the wall that we're building on the
southern border
your wall between the american dream
and chaos joe biden is wholly owned and
controlled by the left-wing mob he has
no clue where he is this is not a sharp
guy
years ago i said to a certain senator i
was very friendly with a democrat who's
the dumbest senator who's the smartest
ever
he gave me a name for the smartest i
said who's the dumbest oh joe biden you
didn't know that
that was 25 years ago that was in prime
time
this is no longer prime time for sleepy
joe
and they do disinformation they make
things up and they make commercials they
make things up i've never seen anything
like it
everything they make up first of all i'm
the one protecting your social security
they say trump remember four years ago
they used to say oh trump will get rid
of social
i have protected your social security
they're going to destroy your social
security
another thing big ten football did i do
a good job
your team better do well you're on the
spot
they better do well are they gonna do
well this year i think so right
but i brought it back but i saw that you
know why i did it actually it sort of
energized me
sleepy joe didn't add that i was against
football that i was against big ten
football give me a break
i was against it when i saw the ad i
said what's the problem with 10
big 10 football they said they're not
going to open why
and they say you know some stupid reason
i said these are strong young people
they're going to do great let's get
going i called the commissioner
kevin good guy and we sort of started
something and we got it rolling we had
big opposition from
a few of the democrats states and
governors you know but we rolled over
the opposition and you have big ten
football congratulations
congratulations
when the far left rioters rampage across
minneapolis
and they rampage across your state
how about your police department let's
just run for your lives
and it's not their fault they were told
to do that you have a good police
department you have good police
but they're not allowed to do their job
no they're not allowed to do their job
remember that they were told to leave
the precinct leave it
and then they knocked the hell out of
that precinct didn't they huh
he had a great mayor great mayor real
really it's a real powerhouse
remember did you ever hear of a man
fiorello laguardia did he ever i don't
think that happened with him
new york i don't think it happened with
rudy giuliani did it
what a great job rudy did you realize
you know rudy's just now really being
appreciated
people forgot how good he was as a man
he was a great man joe biden called the
peaceful protesters he said these are
peaceful protesters
as opposed to sending in the national
guard they didn't want the national
guard
joe biden said you shouldn't send the
national guard
and this one on day after day after day
i pushed and i got it approved the
national guard went and it ended within
what you say half hour
it was about a half an hour you wouldn't
have minneapolis
you better remember this when you go and
vote and your voting starts tonight
please
you'd be saying do you remember when we
had a
city called minneapolis do you remember
used to be over there it's all ashes now
that place was coming down
that was you didn't have anything but
wasn't that a beautiful sight look
all of a sudden you saw one guy in a
black uniform then another then another
on the street remember that street
loaded up with cnn reporters
remember ali velshi shaved head nice
hair
shaved head some people said i should do
that shave the head just give it up
[Music]
no we pulled it i'd go down about 22
points
we pulled it they want to pull
everything nowadays i don't believe in
polls they pull everything
but ali velchi i don't know anything
about the guy but i you know i know
he was standing there this is really
quite a
good scene it's a friendly protest
everyone's acting and behind him the
entire
city was burning it was like block it's
one of the great
pictures of all time the entire city was
burning down
that was your city and it's a shame it
took so long but the governor finally
did it at least you know and if you take
a look at portland the governor can't
quite do it she can't get there i speak
to her all the time come on governor
i can straighten out portland give me
less than an hour just let us have it
for
you know because we have to get the
state has to ask for it after request
it's a shame it's such a shame but in
your case we went
and all of a sudden it was really that
was going to be a bad night too right
remember that about seven o'clock
then they see this guy walk out with
about a 250
000 outfit on that's because it had more
computers of this and then
got the tear gas deal he's got the whole
deal pepper spray
got everything the finest outfit you can
buy believe me we just paid for them and
they look very expensive
so we see one the helmet how about the
helmet with the goggles and
you can see at night you can see a day
you can see whatever the hell you want
so there's one i said oh that's only one
guy then you said another three
then four then you see another ten
they were just getting out of the buses
coming from very friendly territory
and then you have a line and they were
very tight together there was no
social distancing at all which we're
gonna have to speak to them about that
no they would touch her it's true they
were touching right so you had the first
one then you had a second one then you
had a third line then you had them
and then they said march i remember this
guy welty he
hid on the knee with a canister of tear
gas
and he went down he didn't he was down
my knee my knee nobody cared these guys
didn't care they moved them aside
and they just walked right it was like
it was the most beautiful thing
no because after we take all that crap
for weeks and weeks they would take this
crap
and then you finally see men get up
there and go right to
did was it really a beautiful
for law sight order law and order
portland would be easier because it's
more confined we just go being that
would be it but
but you know so they had four or five
lines
then they had lines of different
everybody the same thing did they ever
even
move one step back i don't think so
right it was just a slow walk right
forward then they just started walking
faster faster faster
put a lot of guys in jail tom right but
a lot of guys great congressmen by the
way but a lot of guys in jail
great not good great they put a lot of
guys in jail that night tom
and uh that was the end of it i don't
think you had any problem after that
if you had any flare-ups we'll send them
in again but that's all you do
these are democrat run disasters
look at chicago look at portland
look at you with minneapolis these are
disasters
by the way are they still trying to get
rid of your police force in
minneapolis that's what i have see they
never learned
they never learned they don't look at a
lumber you got a lot of people here
i actually like these you know we have
the arenas we've always filled them up
it's been great
and the arenas are good but usually you
have to travel like 45 minutes this
thing
you you have a hanger the plane becomes
your
your backstop right it's like your
curtain you know it's a curtain you get
a free curtain
we're outside which actually makes
people happy and it even makes the
people that sometimes not everybody here
likes happy because outside is better
you know it's better and we're rounding
the turn on covet by the way our
vaccines are coming a lot of things are
happening
we're rounding the turn we've done a
great job we've done a phenomenal job we
don't get credit for that but we'll
discuss that in a minute
but when you look at it when you look at
it
our country is amazing it's an amazing
country
we love this country and we're not going
to let
we're not going to let radical left
socialist slash communists take over our
country
okay you know they use the word
socialist and socialists aren't great
but communists are a hell of a lot worse
and that's where it would be headed
and we're standing in the way of them
this group of people
but you have a lot of groups of people
just like this every place we go
last night you know where we were you
saw that it was all over the place
right that's a big state that's a great
state
and then i see the fake polls you know
they i just saw a poll here
minnesota i'm down nine i don't think so
i mean i just don't think so
no they said i don't think so
right i don't think so it's uh it's the
craziest thing i've ever said
this is the craziest thing i've seen
president trump is down nine in
minnesota
no i just saw it in the plane see the
plane the good thing about these uh
beautiful air force one right that's the
smaller version of air force one i think
you had a little bit short runway so
they take the smaller to save about
twelve dollars no they took the smaller
one but the great thing about those
beautiful planes they have more
televisions than any plane in history
we have televisions in the closet
on the ceilings on the floors i've never
seen them on the we have them all over
the place
and i'm just coming out and they said
there he is and they said
it's a spattering of people they called
it a spattering
they always do that and yet biden with
the circles right the little say he's
got like four people
in a circle you know why he does the
circles because he can't draw a crowd
so they put a circle like he's supposed
he's trying to be legitimate
but you know he's gonna go by the
science he always says
he doesn't know what the word science is
so they have these like four or five
circles
they put people that way he doesn't have
to be embarrassed when he goes to a high
school gymnasium
and he has like 40 50 people they had
one not so long ago
and you saw this he couldn't draw a
crowd it was a big thing
it was his opening or something couldn't
work out so they
made it a round table so he went in they
only had like 32 people
they said this is very embarrassing one
of his people and that's what they do
they're good some of the people
surrounding him
they'll say anything and do anything
they said let's not make it a speech
there's nobody here
let's make it a round table so these
people are sitting at a table
they had no idea most of them didn't
know anything about politics they didn't
even know why they were there
and now they're sitting on a round table
and they're on television
but that's what it is but they say we
had a smattering of people yes
battering of about what 15 000 people at
about two days notice
and this doesn't include the 10 000
people mike that they turned away i hate
that they turned them away
you know you think with an airport you
wouldn't have to turn anybody away but
they have a certain amount and then
sometimes you have democrats running an
airport and they don't like all these
people here
that's true they don't like but if
you're up to biden
your state would be in ruins and you
know just take a look at what they've
done
and i'm gonna hit it hard you know they
make phony commercials about me
and it gives me the right like how about
the worst word of all the worst i've
ever seen
standing on a grave of a fallen soldier
and then they had some guy a source said
there's no source the source doesn't
exist
they make it up and then they take it
it's called disinformation
you're not supposed to do that and i'm
not even sure if he knows he's too weak
to understand and he's too weak to
control his people but it allows me to
say whatever i want about this guy
and the truth is he's not fit to be your
president he's not mentally fair
if biden's elected extremists like
representative
elaine omar
whatever happened to her you had a great
writer
who has just made a living off writing
about her
and she's done so many criminal acts
isn't it damn disgraceful that she gets
away with it and i have to say
to myself i say how the hell does she
get away with that
and if we do one thing look at general
flynn he didn't even lie they said he
didn't lie right
and he's gone through hell he's gone
through hell
this guy wrote page after page of
criminal acts
well let's see what happens who the hell
knows but between her
and how about aoc aoc
[Music]
arc is running a campaign against the
guy that was supposed to be speaker of
the house right joe crowley
i knew him a little bit i asked him once
i said
are you campaigning against this maniac
he said
no she's just a young girl no problem i
called him on election night
yeah i was going to i was going to say
how did that work out joe
that didn't work he was guys he was
going to speak speaker of the house
she's got a certain talent
but you know all of a sudden she had no
money nothing and all of a sudden she
had two million dollars
and she spent the two million dollars
all over the place her and her boyfriend
whatever happened to her can you imagine
if i do that
she spent the two million dollars you to
look at that
she spent the two million dollars and
big story but that was it that's one
quick story oh
man they probably the guy who wrote the
story lost his job at the new york times
right
he's now unemployed but this is a big
story
she spent two million dollars on
[ __ ]
okay
and if a republican did that they'd be
in jail you know that
it's a different standard and it's a
disgrace and our guys better get on the
ball
look let me tell you how about yesterday
they were talking about russia russia
russia
here we go with russia there's never
been anybody so tough on russia with the
sanctions
remember obama would send pillows i sent
tank busters right to ukraine
i'm the one that exposed the pipeline
with germany
germany pays them billions and billions
of dollars
and then we're supposed to protect
germany from russia i said how does that
work how does that work you're spending
billions of dollars for energy
to rush it's all okay i'm the one that
exposed it what i've done
hey they don't want me to go but if you
look they don't want me to win
russia doesn't want maybe north korea
does because i actually have a very good
relationship with him
and you know we're speaking of north
korea and you know it's okay to have a
relation
you don't have to go to wars we don't
have to lose our great soldiers
we don't have to
it's good if i got along with putin
somebody said he gets along well with
putin i'm saying to myself
but isn't that sort of a good thing is
that bad
he gets along with putin that's a bad
thing but uh
you know you saw the head of the fbi
yesterday so to go russia
russia's looking at our election russia
it's here we go again russia russia
russia
i said what about china what about north
korea what about iran what about
they don't mention anybody else the
narrative seems to be russia
millions of phone calls made not one to
russia
millions of phone calls received not one
to russia
and he goes russia russia then they
asked him about antifa
what do you think about antifa well it's
an ideology
i said no it's not idea it's a bunch of
thugs and anarchists
that are being funded by somebody and
find out
who the somebody is
[Applause]
it's unbelievable unbelievable when you
when you look at this stuff but
seriously take a look at the aoc i call
it aoc plus three you know her three
people that uh she tells what to do and
uh
two million dollars dresses
rent other things you're not supposed to
do that
mr congressman are you allowed to do
that sir you don't do that you don't buy
dresses do you
if he does that's the end of his career
right
no but it's terrible right dumb it's
terrible
it will prosecute him i mean yeah why
not i don't i don't understand it i'll
tell you what
you know once a friend of mine very
sophisticated guy very successful guy
called me up he says you know
from the day you came down the escalator
with our great first lady future first
lady
said from that day people love her
she gave a great speech at the
republican national convention at the
white house she gave a great speech
[Applause]
but said from the day you came down the
escalator with our first lady
from the single day you've been under
investigation
you've been under investigation by
sleazebags
people that now we caught cleaned up
their phones you're not allowed to do
that right mr congressman
my great hockey player you're the
greatest right
but you're not allowed to do that you
know we want their phones oh here they
are oh by the way they happen to be
totally deleted like hillary with the 33
000 emails
i think they should look at that you
know even if they don't find them and i
do believe they're in the state
department i do believe they're in the
fbi
i do believe they're in the fbi but uh
even if you forget about her forget him
you know she said she had 33
000 emails and the emails were for her
yoga lessons not look you know she's not
big into yoga
if she is she's not getting her money's
worth
her yoga lessons
and her daughter's wedding right so it
was about the wedding and the yoga
lesson
so i said uh okay let's give her
five or six each what do you think mike
five or six each
five for the wedding make it 30 make it
a hundred make it a thousand
a thousand for the wedding and for the
yoga let's give her 200.
okay what about all those thousands and
thousands of emails probably classified
so congress
congress so forget about let's assume
they're gone because she deleted them
and then she
acid washed them and then she hit her
phones with a hammer
i get rid of phones i've never hit him
with a hammer not even as president
i see here throw the phone away no no
i've never hit a phone has anybody ever
gotten rid of your phone and taken a
hammer and wiped the hell out of it i
don't think so
so she gets a subpoena from the us
congress not in a lawsuit against some
guy that hates you and you're fighting
and you're fighting or something by the
way you do that you got problems in
court big problems
but she gets a subpoena from
congress u.s subpoena the most important
subpoena you can get
they get the subpoena and after she gets
the subpoena
by a few days everything
is deleted her phones are busted up and
cleaned and wiped
and everything's gone and nothing
happens to her forget about what was on
now think about how how angry it makes
me
when i see it
no how angry could you imagine if i do
that it's a whole different ballgame no
how angry it makes me when i see it and
you know we have
we had an attorney general that didn't
have a clue that was my fault i was
loyal to somebody he endorsed me early
you know why he endorsed me
because i went to mobile alabama and we
had 55 000 people show up at the state
and he said i'd like to endorse you
then after we won he said i'd love to be
attorney general i said no i don't think
so i mean
but after four or five times asking i'm
a loyal person
and i did it the mistake sometimes you
make is because of loyalty but that's
okay
but allowed her to get away with that
is a disgrace it's a disgrace maybe
there's something they can do
so forget about looking for the emails
and they are available
and i guarantee they're in the state
department i guarantee if they're in the
state department that they ought to damn
well find them they're being protected
in the state department
but forget about that almost as good
is the fact that you're not allowed to
do what she did and her lawyers should
pay kendall should pay
equal consequence equal consequences
equal but that's the way it is
and uh but we are making a lot of
progress if you see what's going on you
know i said to myself
i'm going to stay uninvolved i don't
have to chief law enforcement officer
can you believe it
but i think it's better if i stay
uninvolved and i have stayed
uninvolved and we do have an excellent
attorney general
bill barr
and i'll be honest he's a smart guy i
think he's getting tougher and tougher
and tougher every day
i think he's not going to put up with
this stuff i don't think and you know
he's got a lot of people that are
deep staters whatever you want to call
them they fight him at every turn they
fight him fight him find him but he's
getting tougher and tougher i watched
over the last three days i'm saying
wow that's sort of what we're all
waiting for right
but she deletes her emails aoc gets rid
of two million dollars two million
dollars gets rid of it
nothing happens nothing happens and then
she goes
around and calls us all like what the
hell are we
and she controls nancy pelosi actually
nancy pelosi would love to get rid of
her i think you know because
pelosi how about pelosi how about that
how about pelosi pelosi goes out
and says you know i think i have my hair
done
so she goes out and she goes into this
beauty parlor i told the story in
wisconsin last night by the way we had a
great crowd in wisconsin
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you have a feeling about places
you know the problem with minnesota
is that i think since 1972 this hasn't
been won by a republican so
you know you're a little behind the
eight ball when you hear that right
i mean i can understand and wisconsin
rarely but i won
wisconsin unlike minnesota thank you
very much
thank you very much tom thank you
now unlike minnesota but i it's my fault
so i had one speech
left it started at one in the morning i
went to michigan we won michigan that
was another one great state
we brought back so many auto companies
into michigan
we've brought them back but i had one
they had one it was already
voting day it was election day because
by the time i got there was just
scheduled
had i made that one damn stop
to your state we would have won
minnesota i lost by what a half a point
half a point
but i get off the plan and they said
he's in minnesota he's down nine the
recent poll
down nine
[Music]
i believe it's a suppression paul and
you know i'm gonna i have
an instinct about things pretty much
somebody said trump has the greatest
political instincts of the last 100
years one of my enemies said that and i
said no i don't i don't believe i do
i think i have lousy political instincts
but what am i going to tell you let me
just say they said that
and i was very impressed by the
statement in fact i went to my wife i
said you know they say i have the
greatest political instincts in over 100
years
and i said but i don't believe it i
don't i don't want to be beta remember
beta
i was born to run for president that was
the end of his career
beto o'rourke who's in charge of guns by
the way he's going to take your guns
away you know that right biden
sleepy jack sleepy joe's going to take
your guns away remember
beto on the cover of a really crummy
magazine i won't mention today
they got a lot of bad magazines out
there the good news is most of them are
dying
not all of them but beta o'rourke he did
the story and
you know like he was going to defeat
ted cruz he was going to do all these
things ted beat him
and i helped a lot too i was with ted
all the way
and uh and i think ted's appreciated it
but he i even said i'm putting ted cruz
as one of the people for the supreme
court right
and you know why i did it you know why i
did it
because i wanted to make sure that i had
somebody on the list we have about 45
unbelievable people humble of the
smartest the best
the absolute creme de la creme right
the best minds in the country
conservative
they believe in the constitution okay
you know little things little things
like that
but i said you know i have to have
somebody that we're gonna make sure we
get approved and
the only one i could think of is ted
because he's going to get 50 republican
votes and he's going to get 50 democrat
votes he'll do anything to get him out
of the senate
but i joke when i say that to ted but i
say it all the time ted's the only man i
know can get 100 votes from the senate
every single senator's gonna vote for
him but he's a great guy and he's a
brilliant guy
and he's been great he's been really
great i kid when i say that
but you know one of the things we've
done that's so good is the supreme court
we have two supreme court justices
we will have at the end of my term
approximately 300
federal judges and footing for this year
right
so anyway but just to finish there's no
way that i'm nine points down i look at
a crowd so they say
instinct right so i look at a crowd and
whether i have good instinct or not
this is not the crowd of somebody that's
gonna finish second in the state do a
sleepy job
finish second to a guy that cannot put
two sentences together
now it is an ideology it doesn't matter
i could
put that broken piece of wood right
there i could put that out and it's the
same thing as joe it's just an ideology
it's just an idea now historically we
have
the biggest gap in enthusiasm of any
campaign that they've ever polled you
heard that like 36 points
in other words they've got no enthusiasm
for him
i have tremendous enthusiasm as we can
but but he does have
enthusiasm to beat trump his only
enthusiasm is put anybody in there
right put anybody in there he does have
enthusiasm to be trump
nothing for him but to be trump okay but
historically
that never wins when somebody has to
rely on winning because of somebody as
opposed to winning because
people love you people respect you
and sean hannity did something the other
night he said would you have
this man if you owned a mcdonald's
hamburger stand in a reasonably busy
area
would you have joe biden running that
stand the answer is no he doesn't have
the energy
he doesn't so he can't run the country
no seriously i thought it was good i
never thought of it
you wouldn't have him running your
business you wouldn't have him running a
mcdonald's
i have to say or wendy's i have a friend
he owns wendy's he always gets a kid you
have a mention wendy's okay what
but you know you wouldn't do it because
he couldn't do it and yet he's running
for the presidency
he's got no energy i made a comment that
somebody had
low energy that was the end of his
political career
but joe's energy is far lower it's far
lower
no it's it's far lower than jeb jeb was
on the low side
but joe is like he's off the scale right
joe's got nothing going today biden
delivered remarks barely to a union
after spending 47 years giving their
jobs to china and foreign countries
in exchange for campaign cash how about
his statement hey we talk about aoc
being crooked she's 100 crooked okay
but we're talking about that look at
omar she came in here did she marry her
brother where's that writer then right
now that writer should be giving the
pulitzer prize he never will be
he should be though you know the amazing
thing all of these writers new york
times washington post
russia i share russia trump russia
russia russia
i had 19 people all brilliant
all radical left all hillary clinton
people actually not even a never trumper
from bush
okay all hillary clinton people mostly
almost everywhere they were all
democrats how about this
you're being investigated by 19
democrats that are smart people
okay smart people so my friend says you
know
you are the most honest person in the
world
you've taken three years of total
investigation
you don't think they've gone over my
taxes they went over the biggest tax
firm in the country
the most prestigious they went over
everything they spent 48 million dollars
it comes out now it's about
48 million dollars investigating me
before i won and after i won and we
caught them spying on my campaign that's
what they were really doing
and now with the phones i think there's
like 22 or 24 people you heard this one
they said no no no we made a mistake
when we deleted our phone
you know what they had to do to make
that mistake like 19 different formulas
right
i don't even know how you delete a phone
i didn't know you could do it
but they all made the exact same mistake
that's not good
that's not good so let's see what
happens to them it's a criminal act you
know that right it's a criminal act
it's criminal weissman's a bad guys put
a lot of people in jail that shouldn't
be in jail weisman
he's a bad guy he's on cnn all the time
or msnbc
which is i call it msdnc because it's
the same thing
owned by a company called comcast that
everyone over here with an end not an m
khan like a con job comcast
they spend a fortune on public relations
comcast has
delivered to you the news all the news
and they spend a fortune on and then i
go up and make one speech and i call
them comcast and that's the end of the
pr for the year
they are a bad group of people they're
sick i mean they're sick people
they're sick and evil people but and
they want bad things for our country
and they don't report the news you know
in the old days
when you used public airways free
you had to get a license i keep saying
if they're reporting fake news how come
they can keep getting a license
whether it's abc whether it's nbc
cbs or of course cnn which is i mean
it's one of the great jokes of all time
cnn
or msdnc but they're cables i guess
there's a different standard
but when you're using the public
airwaves free
okay free aren't you supposed to get a
license so you ask my people that i ask
a couple of guys and
i never really get an answer i just want
to know a simple question do you have to
report the truth
when you're using free airways and make
it a fortune with commercials and
everything else
and i never get the right answer because
there are people down deep it's crazy
but we're getting down to all of it a
lot of progress has been made i think
you're starting to see it
we're trying to beat a terrible group of
deep state people you know i came to
washington
think of it think of it i came to
washington
and i had 24 years of people putting
people in
office and then you could probably add
another four to that and another four to
that
i had many many years decades of people
putting so i came
never been to washington i guess 17
times i never stayed over
right never slept over i was there 17
times i tell the
story i was in washington in my entire
life dc
17 times never slept over ever not once
and all of a sudden i'm riding down
pennsylvania avenue
and i'm with a beautiful woman on my
right named melania
think of this and i had about 400
motorcycles in front of me
and we're in a cavalcade of about 128
cars
most of them having about 15 submachine
guns inside
there's more fire power that's good
but we're riding down the beautiful
pennsylvania avenue
and i look outside at those police i
love our police we got to see that
but i had everything i had police i had
military i had
soldiers i had everything you could
possibly have you never saw so much
power and strength and beauty the beauty
and they were so proud they're all
saluting they're so proud they're
happy to have gotten rid of that crowd
that was there before us they're proud
they're they're great they're police you
know every single
police force i think endorsed me i got
the one yesterday from chicago that's
that easy
chicago endorsement new york's finest
industry
florida ohio
every i mean everybody i don't know that
he's gotten
one vote then he says he's he can't
mention the words low on order
but i'm driving down the street and i
look at my
wife i say do you believe it
i'm the president of the united states
that's the good thing but can you
believe it
[Applause]
and then i get to the most beautiful
house in the world i can have mar-a-lago
and all of them but i'll tell you the
white house is still the white house no
matter how you do it i get to this
gorgeous
beautiful place and i'm up at the
incredible suite level and there's
abraham lincoln's suite it's called the
lincoln bedroom remember clinton used to
lease it out to people for money
they never changed do they remember when
barbra streisand
which is another beauty by the way
but remember barbra streisand used to
stay in that suite
but which was the only problem i had
with it
but tell me no but i do like her voice i
do i really do
some of them i don't like even their
voices
but she used to stay there and i'm
standing in the lincoln bedroom the
history the whole thing the bed
the desk the gettysburg address
the beautiful four score and seven years
ago this beautiful
gettysburg address he wrote it there
and also on his carriage ride up to
gettysburg
he delivered the gettysburg address and
they say the only one that got worse
press than i did was abraham lincoln did
anyone ever hear that
and i said no way they get worse maybe
he got bad but no way he gets worse
now people are starting to say you know
it's probably true i think you get the
word
now they're actually they used to say no
no newt gingrich great guy he said
nope abraham lincoln got the worst press
they were worse to him than anybody
he was a very depressed person his wife
was very depressed
it was a depressed kind of a thing you
know there's an award in a revolution
and uh he was getting beaten a lot by
robert e lee they want to rip his statue
down all over the place but robert e lee
robert e lee was a whether you like them
or not whether you like statues or not
you know they don't rip statues down
anymore assigned to law
10 years in jail
but robert e lee won many many battles
in a row
and it was supposed to be over in one
day you know it's supposed to end
immediately because the north was too
powerful
for the south but it just shows when you
have
leaders when you have a great general
and robert e lee he would have won
except for gettysburg and
that was because his general was killed
who's going to
lead gettysburg never fight uphill
me boys never fight uphill he heard they
were going uphill
stop them stop them but we had no cell
phones in that day right
congressman no cell phones so they sent
the horses to
stop them stop them but it was too late
they fought uphill and they got
slaughtered
that's what happened but robert e lee
these were
incredible things but i hope you i hope
you appreciate
that we had a period of time when they
were ripping down
all of the statues and monuments and i
said to my people four months ago i said
this is crazy
these people and they don't even know
you know they they started ripping down
abraham lincoln when they hit lincoln
i said wait a minute this is the man and
you can't do
then they hit george washington thomas
jefferson they hit
everybody they even hit gandhi all
gandhi wanted was one thing peace may we
have peace
ripped out a statue i don't think you
have any idea what they're doing i think
they're just
a bunch of thugs okay you want to know
that they're i think they're fun
but they were going to march on
washington and they were going to rip
down
a statue of abraham lincoln you know the
exact statue and it was
up very nicely up now by the way they
can take them down illegally they go
through congress as a way of doing it
but you know they didn't want to do it
that way and they were marching on
washington and i said do we have any
laws about this they said
no sir now in congress the way it is now
you can't you know the most you get is
about uh
a ten dollar fine you rip down a five
million dollar
statue you get a ten dollar fine right
you know it's different world
that's uh when it was strong they had
laws but we told and found this old act
and the old act said if you rip down a
monument or a statue
you get 10 years in prison they call it
prison not jail which sounds even worse
i said bring that sucker up immediately
to the oval office because a lot of
people coming to washington
they were going to march on the
jefferson memorial do you believe this
the jefferson
memorial we grow up the jefferson
memorial
they were going to march on the
jefferson memorial
they were going to do damage to our
beautiful jefferson
memorial after thomas jefferson and i
did predict that a friend of mine said
you know two years ago
you said next we'll be robert e lee
and then comes washington and jefferson
and lincoln
they'd never stop the only thing they
understand is strength remember that
they don't understand weakness there is
nothing you can do
these really stupid heads of these
corporations
that give hundreds of millions of
dollars it's like blackmail money right
but these stupid people that run they
get 40 million dollars a year and
they're weak
okay they're weak but the only thing
these people they're anarchists the only
thing they understand is strength
so i said let me see this uh document
i said wow this is a very strong
document and we have
derek is here one of my attorneys he did
a great job i don't know where the hell
derek is he's around here
actually he's heard this before although
not quite this is you're getting a very
unique speech tonight you know
i mean unlike joe i haven't even looked
at the teleprompter this guy
move it up move it up i can't move it up
i haven't looked at it the poor
teleprompter guy is sitting there what
do we do
we're on line two of the teleprompter he
said what do we do
no unlike joe i have not looked at the
teleprompter
oh that poor joe you know what's the
worst part about him looking at the
teleprompter
the worst part is that means that the
fake news media
is giving him the questions
right like donna brazile who was
brilliantly hired by fox fox has changed
a little bit
ladies and gentlemen donna brazile who
was fired
by cnn because she cheated and she gave
crooked hillary the
questions to the debate how would you
like to be me
they gave her questions to the debate
and i still won the debate and she had
all the questions
how do you do that donna brazile is
ladies and gentlemen
she's going to work for fox so that's
great that's big difference
big difference between four years ago
and now a lot of things have changed
but i'll tell you what's changed is the
fact that we have more enthusiasm now
than we did four years ago it's amazing
right
but just to get back to the other so i
signed that
wonderful executive order instituting
this really
tough law and it says 10 years it
doesn't say you know
you get 10 years but you can take it
down to 3 weeks
it says 10 years so these guys had just
gotten there i had a news conference
because i had to let them know about it
right
we've got many people in jail right now
that from before
nobody even talked about taking statues
down no but i looked at the
andrew jackson right with the ropes
and i'll tell you the police did a great
job and mark meadows did a great job
he said charge they charged and they
took these guys out
and they were fairly tough but the
police were much tougher dc police they
did a great job
they were watching and they weren't able
to do anything mark meadows said
charge it was like it was like from 200
years ago it was crazy
they charged and they beat the hell out
of these guys
or you wouldn't have or you wouldn't
have that great
statue on the horse of
our great general he was a great general
and he was a very good
president at least at least a good
president but he was a great general the
battle of new orleans right
and they had this incredible picture
andrew jackson and they were going to
rip it down remember the ropes wrapped
around the horse right and the guy
standing up there
just saw his he went to jail two days
later we had all the evidence we needed
thank you for that i want to thank you
fake news
[Applause]
we called the fake news we said can we
save that plea
when they said no we just said we'll
take it off tivo that's okay don't worry
about
one of the greatest inventions in
history tivo better than television
because television is useless without it
so so we signed it and all of a sudden
these same guys that were watching and
they
left nobody showed up the next day
they're gonna have 25 000 people
they had 24 people five of them were
brought to prison
okay and the next day they said well we
we're going to save it for saturday
night
and saturday night nobody showed up and
nobody has showed up
in four months to take down a statue
because they're
still because you know why
they look and they say i want to take
down that statue i'm going to take down
that statue
that statue's coming down and then
somebody says you know it's 10 years in
jail they go that's too much i'm getting
out of here
it's true 10 years is not acceptable
mike right
10 years is a lot to rip down a statue
have a little fun
especially when they have no idea what
they're ripping down but we have an
idea what they're ripping down they're
ripping down in many cases greatness
they're ripping down our past they're
ripping down
our history and that's where these guys
begin they take away your history
you look at the middle east you look all
over look what
isis did look what all of them do they
go down and they rip
they go into museums and they break
everything and they rip everything
they want to take away your past they're
not taking away the past
of the united states of america
not as long as i'm here
what do you do you want me to go back on
teleprompter anybody no no
okay here's a question my poor guy must
be having a fit he's over there he's so
good at this stuff
he's on line three he's saying sir
should i just turn the sucker off would
you rather go teleprompter or
freelance
[Applause]
isn't it nice when you have the option
because you have this and you have the
option to go on
see joe doesn't have the option he
doesn't have the option
but if biden wins china wins and it's
very simple
it's very simple by contrast i rescued
the minnesota iron range you know i did
that just so you know
oh biden i call him moe biden it's too
long to say obama
and bye so just call him a bud because i
don't care about
everyone said oh no he's in trouble
obama is now campaigning hey he can't
paint last time
harder than hillary i said no i want him
to campaign because he brings out the
base he brings out our base
and i'm only here because of him and joe
if they were
a good president and vice president i
wouldn't be here i had a very good life
before
i'm doing this i'm doing this because
they did
such a crummy job
i'm only here because of it i could
right now be having a very beautiful
life of luxury and here i am
at the hangar in minnesota with
15 or 20 or 25 000
and thousands of people that couldn't
get in and i'm working my ass off i
could be at home having a good time
wonderful time
but the one thing i say this
but i say this i say this look i could
be home
so home was new york i had to bail out
because it was too crazy it's everything
has fallen apart
but home is so sad what the democrats
have done
to our great new york between a governor
and a mayor the crime is through the
roof
the corruption is incredible it's a sad
thing that's happened to new york
hopefully it'll come back by somebody
somebody will go in there and do like a
rudy
you know when rudy took over it was so
bad and
they were looking for somebody and they
thought he was the guy because he was a
tough guy
but somebody has to go in and clean it
up somebody has to you know
this mayor he let go of a billion
dollars worth of police he let go he
actually believed
the nonsense about defunding the police
and they're all going to do it
they're all going to do it and your
people are going to do it and you really
i'm
being totally serious damn you've got to
go out and you've got to vote for trump
you got to you got to break this spell
from 1974
i mean you saw kenosha we what we did in
what we did for other places you saw the
kenosha
and that was gone that was all gone that
place was gone we sent in the troops
it was uh incredible what we did and
they did it
on day three day three is better than
two weeks later like in
minneapolis right now but they did it
and we've done a great job and the
people of that great state they
understand it
and i just hope the people of your state
of minnesota understand it
because we don't have too many more
chances with this stuff we really don't
we don't have the luxury of sitting back
and saying let's have
four years of this maniac vice president
that i paid that he picked
who treated him worse than any other
person that's why i say the one per
person
that he won't pick my great instincts
right
the one person he won't pick is kamala
because she called him a racist she
tried to me to him
you know he was me tood i've just been
me too darling what does that mean
but they tried to me to him and she was
the one that brought it up
remember tara she was the one that
brought it up
and then he goes ladies and gentlemen
i'd like to pick
wait a minute let me get her name here
how do you pronounce it
it's with a comma like a comma right
like a comma remember he couldn't
pronounce her name he was saying her
name wrong and she tried to interrupt
him know my name was
kamala like comma i remember that
like a comma right
h1n1 that's right joe remember that
h1n1 and how bad did he do in that
though how about that
how bad did he do so number think of it
he's out there now today
it was pathetic by the way did you see
the anderson cooper thing last night
you have to watch i don't want to watch
but i have an obligation you know i'm
competing here at somebody
you don't want to compete and say i'm
not going to watch my competition who
wouldn't
it's boring but i got to watch
and he got through it he made a couple
of really the chicken thing was bad you
know he
said chicken many many times and it was
a little strange i thought it was over
and
he pulled it back he was able to pull it
back but anderson is
again and he interviewed me he's tough
you know he can be tough
nothing against him he could be very
tough but last night he was in rare
form he was uh thank you very much for
being here mr vice president are you
enjoying
the run and compare that with my shot
where they asked me
about doing abc with george
stephanopoulos i mean i think it was
great i think it worked out great
i call it you know what i call it debate
prep i call that free debate prep
but you know it's nasty it's a little
nasty that people and they i didn't say
no you got to change the rules no give
me the questions i want to use a
teleprompter
to answer how about that though mr
vice president uh i'd like to know your
feeling on
nuclear warfare and how does that relate
to china and russia
and where are they in the race right uh
well you can't have this as your
president
i don't care forget about me you can't
do this
the power the the importance and the
power of this position are too great
you can't do it you know i've learned a
lot as president
but one thing i learned is that
president xi
of china is sharp you ever see him
standing with the two million men
walking in front everybody's the same
height they're wearing hats there it's
like a pool table right blah blah blah
and he's standing there by himself and
he's looking like he's not playing games
right there's no games he's sharp as you
can be
and i had a great relationship but now i
feel differently you know
we made a great trade deal and now i
feel differently but he's as sharp as
you can be putin
as sharp as you can be kim jong-un you
would have been in a war
with north korea 100 100
i asked obama did you ever call him
i see he said he said that was the
toughest problem we had
and we get along remember about a month
ago two months ago they broke into the
demolition
and they said oh he's going to attack i
said no he's not don't worry about it
i got to know him very well we have a
good relationship people said
he has a good relationship with kim
jong-un
that's terrible i said no that's good
but do you remember
it was going to be nuclear war and i got
along with him
then they said trump made a terrible
deal
he's given so much to north korea what
did i give
how is it like a semi debate with this
idiot
a reporter he's given a lot to north
korea what did i give
i don't know
sanctions sanctions you you took away no
i didn't actually i
increased the sanctions very
substantially what did you give what did
i give tom
ah okay so after about four days i
couldn't answer because i gave nothing
except i gave heart because i don't want
to see people killed on their side
either i don't want to see people kill
okay we'd win that we'll win them all we
have
the great we're conceived by man
we've rebuilt our military to a level
that nobody ever thought possible
okay nobody ever thought possible
and then the fake news and i said that a
couple weeks ago remember i said
we have created the most powerful
weapons
known to man it's true we have weapons
that are so advanced
that president xi putin everybody
with the envy of the world but they
don't know quite what we have but they
know we have stuff that they never even
heard of before
and some schmuck back there said i think
he's giving away classified information
no all i'm doing is telling the world we
have the most powerful weapons in the
world i'm not even saying what kind
you don't even want to know about it and
i never god
help us if we ever have to use them but
we have the most powerful weapons ever
conceived by man
you know they have the missile the super
duper hydrosonic i call it the super
duper it goes five times faster than a
normal
missile right we have one goes much
faster than that but russia got that
information from the obama
administration
russia stole that information you knew
that you knew that
russia got the information then they
built it but we have now one that's much
faster
much faster than that that's like a slow
missile
that's like considered a slow missile
but i said it was incredible two weeks
ago i said we have the finest the best
the most incredible
sadly the most deadly and we never want
to use it but we have the greatest
weapons
ever in history by a factor of 10 by a
factor of 10
and they said they went crazy he's given
away classified
these people are sick all i'm doing is
saying that we rebuilt our military
2.5 trillion dollars all built in the
usa
every single ounce
[Applause]
we have fighter jets f-35 that are so
good you can't see it
and i went to see the program and i met
some of the pilots and these guys are
better looking than tom cruise
they're tougher they're stronger they're
bigger they're more powerful
they're smarter and i like tom cruise by
the way because i mean you can't get
much better than top gun right great
movie right you can't get better i like
tom cruise but these guys are better
looking than
they got the crew cut they got the crap
under their eyes they got the whole deal
they're smart as hell so i said so
captain let me ask you how good is the
f-35 real good sir best player we've
ever had oh great
i said uh how do you compare that with
uh what russia has
well ours is better for a specific
reason sir
you can't see it what does that mean
well when we fight they cannot see us
sir we are so stealth
now that doesn't mean in three years
that it won't be obsolete because that's
what happens that's the problem with
that business
you come up with a new computer and two
weeks later it's obsolete
that's why you always like real estate
you know you have a piece of real estate
but no it's true i wouldn't be good in
that business you should work work work
and then you started the next one
because the last one is god
that's why i always talk about walls and
wheels right
when the democrats were saying walls are
old-fashioned well they're right about
that
but they work remember that all we had
to go through in congress
and that wall's going up think of that
we're building 10 miles a week 10 miles
a week of the top
the wall and our numbers on the border
are the best they've ever been
the best they've ever been
[Music]
but we're building 10 miles of wall a
week we're up to about 330
miles and we'll have it finished very
soon and it's having a tremendous impact
on drugs it's having a tremendous impact
on
all of the different things human
trafficking in women
in women it's not even children
they traffic in women it's because of
the internet you know you think of that
as almost an
ancient kind of a crime right but it's
not it's a very modern crime and it's an
unbelievably profitable crime the
traffic in women
little bit children but mostly women
where they'll put three or four women in
the back in the trunk of a car
and they'll go through the border they
can't do it anymore and we we're
catching them we have people that do
nothing but look for the traffic because
to me the traffickers are the biggest
scum in the world
[Applause]
and thank heavens for ice and thank
heavens for border patrol
because these people do a job that you
don't want
i know mike doesn't want it you wouldn't
even be good at it mike he'll do a
commercial about it that's what he'll be
does he have the longest commercials in
history i say
mike lindell i say mike the pillow man i
say mike is the single greatest
purchaser of commercials in history
i want him to buy my commercials i say
you know we spent 20 million dollars i
saw like
two commercials he spends two dollars
and he's got the whole day
on fox i said let mike buy our
commercials will you i don't know what
the hell you do but whatever it is you
better tell bit the secret
greatest purchaser of commercials but
we have done some job with that and uh
the traffickers
the drugs are way down now we got upset
with the
pandemic but i watched biden today
talking about if only trump
moved one week sooner one week so let's
go ready
so you know he was against the ban right
because he didn't think we had a problem
so he was against the ban he didn't know
that
china was heavily infected he doesn't
even know what china is in my opinion
but he was against the ban these guys
write stuff out for him and he tries to
read it doesn't do well with it
so he was against it but now his new
thing is
if only i moved one week earlier but i
was earlier than everybody
if you think about it i had nice guy
dr fauci i had another dance a lot of
doctors they were all telling me no no
you don't have to do that
right tom knows that very well you don't
have to do that sir
you don't have to do that you don't have
to do that at all
and uh you know one of those things i
was very early
and i banned and everybody admits that
had i not banned highly infected wuhan
wuhan province right highly infected we
would have had
hundreds of thousands of more deaths and
then you had the chart i put it up
yesterday i'm doing these news
conferences we're finally getting the
word of course that we did a great job
but i'm doing news conferences now every
day
you know even if they list highly i call
them the highly rated
news conferences and i go before these
crazy people they're screaming at you
know screaming like
maniacs you know it's not the way they
treat sleepy joe
he'd melt if they ever did a number on
this guy would be there he'd be
laying on the floor crying get me out of
here darling
where's my wife get me out of here
please darling
they're so nasty to me today what
happened we go through it every single
day
but you think about it and he said
if only trump moved faster but he's the
one that two months later
called me xenophobic and he called me a
racist
because i was banning china which was
heavily infected
and then he said don't ban europe well i
looked at
italy big problem i love italy i love
the people of italy
but they were heavily infected france i
looked at france i looked at
spain they even had spikes recently did
you see
and we're doing great we're rounding it
with or without but we're gonna have
with but you know with is better but
with or with that we're rounding that
corner
and we're rounding it fast and they
don't want to give us any credit because
they want to keep this up till
november 4th and on november 4th the
press will probably say
let's say something stupid happened the
press will say
i got to admit he did a damn good job
right no no and the other clown will be
in office
you know we did a thing called price
transparency i signed it it's effective
as a very complicated
it's on your medical and we did price
transparency
it's the biggest thing that's bigger
than healthcare what do you see your
prices you can go now to hospitals you
can price operations you can price
everything
it's a massive thing the man who did it
the man who did it
and i took a lot of heat and i'm doing
favored nations drugs meaning whatever
the lowest in the world is we have to
pay the same you know
that's the good news the bad news is the
drug companies the doctors
everybody's angry at me actually under
price transparency
the good hospitals and the good doctors
benefit tremendously
but the bad ones don't and you have
price transparency
and it goes into effect on january 1st
could you imagine if this sleepy guy
gets it
and they say like february march april
something
they say unbelievable what happened
to prices it's dropping like crazy
and they'll say what a job he's doing as
president and i'm the one that signed it
i said could you put it into effect but
statutorily
it has to mature mature mature
so the earliest i could get is january
1st it's like
it's like crazy you know another one
i'll give you another one
i'll give you another one so air force
one so that's the 757 but they have a
747 which is the big air force one
uh i think they just disrespected the
people of minnesota today they gave us
the little
no actually it's because of the runway
in fact when we landed you know what
they said they said sir
we have a very short runway could you
please hold on i said i trust these
pilots by the way these pilots are the
best pilots
when you fly the president of the united
states
he's waving from the window when you fly
the president of the united states you
are the best flyer
they take the best air force guys they
take the best marines in the helicopters
marine one but when you're flying these
planes you can land that sucker you have
no problem there's no
mishits there's no let's go around i
can't quite make it sir
these guys are phenomenal you've got to
see what they look like you know
everyone's in perfect shape i look at
him central casting every one of them
they're great thank you fellas
thank you but i'll tell you a little
story
so air force one is a very old plane
it's beautiful but it's an old 747 right
31 years old and other people didn't
want to do it
but it was time to get a new one right
it was time you got to get a new plane
and actually air force one i'll give you
a little secret it's actually two planes
okay
they get two it's a hell of a way to
travel you know if one's not working
perfectly use the other one okay
but they get to so air force one
they negotiated a price and they
had it down for 5.7 billion that sounds
expensive and it's ridiculous
but that was done by the obama
administration right it was done by the
obama administration
and that's okay but no administration
obama bush
they didn't want to do it because it
sounds luxury but at some point you got
to buy a
plane for the country and these arab
countries would have their beautiful 747
800s 900s pour in and they were gorgeous
and believe it or not
the new plane is a much bigger plane
much bigger wingspan
it's a much more beautiful plane it's
modern you know
think of it 31 years old air force one
is 31 years old the main air force one
not this
there's a great plane but the big one 31
years old so
you're representing the country but they
didn't want to do it because they chose
luxury
so i said uh i get to office i said
whatever happened to air force one how's
it doing sir
we made a deal for a new one under the
obama administration oh
you did good how much 5.7 billion
i said that's a lot of money 5.7 for two
planes in all fairness
now it's very technical it's very you
know there's a lot of stuff i won't talk
about it because i don't want to give
away any classified information
just trust me it's the most
sophisticated sucker you've ever seen in
your life okay
think of getting into a plane that costs
5.7 billion right
but it's the most sophisticated two
planes
so i said how much is it 5.7 a general
came in an air force
general great guy handsome guy or all so
good looking these people i said
so general what are we paying what is
the what's the price
sir it's uh 5.7 million dollars and
we're ready to go sir could you sign it
it sounds like a lot of money to me
general 5.7 million for two airplanes
uh can't we get a better price no sir
this was negotiated by the obama
administration
the obama administration this was
negotiated sir by barack hussein obama
and i said oh that's good sounds very
high
so here's what i'm going to do tell
boeing we're not taking the plane we
have no interest and it's too much
right that's what i do this is by the
way this is one of many stores
isn't this better than going and saying
i saved your iron range
and i said but please remember i did
this too and i can do away with this
stuff but
i did this too i did this too
please remember that because you know i
have all this list of incredible things
i've done for minnesota i won't even
touch you because frankly
i'm tired of repeating what i've done
for all these different states
i mean i did all this stuff and then i
hear i'm nine down i don't believe it by
the way suppression
so i said to the general i said general
uh 5.7 billion billion not me a billion
that sounds very hard to me general i've
bought a lot of planes in my life and a
lot of helicopters i know a lot about it
how could it be five sir that's the best
price they could get
we only have one day to do it
i said cancel it general cancel the
order it was signed actually
yes sir i said you have the right to
cancel yes sir i do
we negotiated a great deal i said oh
good cancel
yes sir i'm pleased to tell you
something sir we have a breakup fee
we made a great deal sir i said you did
no
you have a breakup fee you mean you
can't just cancel it for nothing and
cancel it you don't have to pay a
breakup
i know about breakup fees no sir we have
a breakup fee okay how much is it
sir we can break it up for 250 million
dollars
i said whatever so you mean to tell me
that to cancel the order costs 250
million dollars in other words we give
them 250 million we get nothing
i said general don't cancel the order
just tell them i'm very unhappy
right this is what these guys say good
businessmen by the way these guys right
here mike
they might be better than you i don't
even know he may be the next governor
you know mike lindell may be
you should run you should run
he is my complete and total endorsement
you should run you'd be a hell of a
governor
at least you know one thing minnesota
would be well promoted
[Applause]
minnesota mike run for governor please
so he says 250 million
dollars it's 250. sir i'm so proud of
that
i said you may be proud but i'm not so i
said general don't
give them notice because i don't want to
write a check for 250 and get nothing i
don't think i could explain that to the
american public
so tell them you're really unhappy we're
not going to make the deal but just do
it
verbally and yes sir
and then i spoke to the head of boeing a
very nice guy they had some rough times
since then i had a couple of really bad
things happen
terrible really terrible this was early
on before the problems that they had
and but he is he's a high quality guy
and i said to him
dennis we have to start it with a it's
got to have a 3 on the front of it what
do i know i just know that if they're
5.7 and if i do something with a three
he said no i can bring it down to 5.5
billion
so i say well that's not bad i saved 200
million dollars in about a minute and a
half phone call so so far i'm not there
but it's not good enough i'm not happy
i said no we got to really think about
canceling it
and i can't go to airbus which is made
in europe you know it's
a little hard i got to go to the
competitor i can't say i'm going to buy
the air force one from a european
company that doesn't work too well
so i just said my only option was to say
look i just don't want it
just put it aside put it aside he calls
me up a few days later
well we can do a little bit better than
that i said dennis has to have
a three in front of it dennis got to
have a three you know like a three three
anything but gotta have a three in front
of it so he said no no no
after one month we signed a contract for
3.9 billion dollars right
same exact thing
same exact one actually slightly better
we got an extra generator
and then boeing came to me and i know
how to
you know i love to negotiate i do got
that from my father my father was a good
negotiator
and i loved to negotiate so they came to
me sir we can put an extra stairway this
is the big
747 and remember this is a big much
bigger than the old 747
sir it gets very windy up there i
noticed that your hair is blowing all
over the place
but we can buy a stairwell for the plane
and it comes under it's like a corkscrew
right at the bottom of the plane you
know you're very high off the ground big
big thing
and it opens up and you'll if it's
raining or windy
you're covered sir because it's under
the plane you're totally sheltered
i said that sounds great so it's a
corkscrew
stairwell i said how much is that
general
50 i said 50.
what a deal so for 50 000 i can get a
stairway
no sir 50 million dollars i said forget
about the stairwell forget it
it's true he said 50. i really thought
he meant 50 000
so these are just some little stories i
guess i must like minnesota to go on one
of these deals
but boy
did you get your money's worth tonight
did you get is anybody having a bad time
did you get your money's worth because
you've heard the other one we've done
this and we've cut your taxes there we
built up the military bigger and better
and we're the number one in history and
regulation cuts which is the biggest
thing
and the judges which we've done at a
luck i mean at a level like nobody's
ever done everything we've done
nobody has done more in three and a half
years
no administration three and a half those
first three and a half years nobody even
comes close and you know it's a funny
thing
i say it all the time i've been saying
it for a long time
and the fake news nobody even questions
me about it and you know if i was wrong
they would but they can't question me
because
when you see right to try we took care
of our vets
we just got a 91 approval rating from
the vets 91 it's never happened
we got choice approved we got
accountability approved
drugs are way down we got a little
setback with this whole situation where
you know uh these shutdowns caused a lot
of problems with drugs a lot of
everything but drugs were
way down we had our best year in the
history of our country last year
and we're gonna have the best year we're
gonna have a better year coming up
that's why you have an obligation to
vote
for the guy that got you there
and
and remember this and and i really
appreciate that
thank you but i appreciate this because
nine democrat mayors of cities in the
iron range
you know that have endorsed me
over sleepy joe
what do you like better sleepy joe or
slow joe what's better let's just do a
poll we do a poll
we do a poll i do free polls you know
these polls are all they charge you a
fortune for this stuff they interviewed
three people and you know
and they charge you a million dollars we
interviewed 233 people
i got thousands of people here let's do
a free what do you like better as a
nickname
slow joe or sleepy just so let's go wait
slow joe first okay so just scream if
you like it so you have a choice
slow joe they're both very appropriate
slow joe or sleepy joe ready slow joe
[Applause]
i think we're gonna have a winner sleepy
joe
[Applause]
a lot of people say i'm too nice at
sleepy jail that i'm actually being too
nice i don't know
he's a sleepy guy but biden
is going to shut down your iron wrench
remember it wasn't just the tariffs i
put on your competitors that were
dumping
iron ore and steel and everything else
in our country like it was garbage okay
and it was garbage
steel too it was all sand based steel
real crap
it wasn't that but when you think of it
they wrote it out it was you didn't have
environmentally the right you know
somebody said oh well he got a bid
because he was good with negotiating
with these other countries
it wasn't that i opened it up
i signed an order i signed an executive
order because
obama took your iron range and biden
took your iron range away and i'll never
forget the day i did it and tom was
there
a man i don't know who he is he's
probably in this massive audience
but he came up to me and he was a rough
guy and he never cried in his life
including at childbirth he didn't cry at
childbirth
but he was crying and he said sir you
gave our life back to us
because obama took our heart out when he
closed
up the iron man said you gave our heart
that
it's true so i just want to thank
those cities i mean you know when a
democrat mayor
we have now a lot of now we have
additional so these are democrat
politicians and they came to
they not claimed that two weeks ago they
endorsed us and you know it's a great
thing
we're finding that all over the country
democrats for trump
politicians that got elected as
democrats i don't think they changed
their party affiliation
but they endorsed trump they're all in
the
iron range area and
larry cuffey is here larry cuffy
[Music]
where's larry where is he where larry
how are you
i really why did you do that like that's
so nice i appreciate it
boy are you good i wish he had a mic he
said because you're the best
candidate we could ever i love this guy
said you're the best candidate we could
ever hope for
larry
thank you lad that's beautiful i
appreciate it we'll do a good job we're
not going to let you down and they're
doing a good job over there they're
digging digging dig we must right
it's all gone because of me that's cool
man thank you
no he signed an executive order shutting
it down just shutting it down
and i hear it's got the best iron ore
anywhere in the world that's what i hear
the quality is
the best and it's like an unlimited
amount you know what i'm not talking
about a little this is a
massive operation with thousands of
people and everything else and for me it
was very easy
andrea zouponstich where is she
where is where's andrea thank you very
much that's really nice
i'm glad i'm glad that at least you got
a good location right
that's great i appreciate it very much
you're all friends i guess chris
vreeland where's chris chris freeland
chris
whiskers the mayor
thank you chris thank you chris thank
you very much
kathy brando kathy brandel
thank you kathy i hope you're having a
good time tonight we're not going to let
you down you know that we're open that
sucker is open we're not closing it well
think of this though if biden gets in
it's closed
he said he's going to close it how about
this guy
no fracking you're not going to frack on
stage with all these
crazy people and they don't want any
energy you know they think everything's
going to run by wind
which costs you a fortune about 20 times
more than what we have
and doesn't work but think of it all of
these people
and they say what about fracking
fracking is the modern technology
and so they all said no no we're all
against everyone's against fracking what
about you
yes i'm against it too now he's against
it for months
he gets it now he's in favor of it but
he's sort of grandfathering it you know
it's a very weak
well i'd like to grandfather fracking if
i'm a fracker i don't want to be
grandfathered i want to have it or not
have it right
he wants the grandfather fracking uh
always go with their first statement
okay so i was in texas two weeks ago we
had crowds
mike we had crowds that went from the
airplane
to the well to the drilling well where
we went to see a well
and we saved the industry because i got
russia and saudi arabia to cut back 10
million barrels it actually was probably
18 ended up being i think 18 five
million barrels and it saved the
industry and yet you're still paying
very low gasoline prices at the pump but
we saved 10 million jobs
you know but i'm in texas and let me
tell you texas appreciated because that
industry was in deep trouble because all
of a sudden with the pandemic there was
no demand there was nobody driving there
was no demand
nobody ever saw anything like it so i'm
in texas and i said to the crowd it was
a great crowd
and we must had a hundred thousand
people on the road on the highways and
roadways waving and they had the most
beautiful trump flags i wanted to stop
where did you buy that flag
the most beautiful flags of me and our
great vice president is mike pence doing
a good job by the way
that's why he did such a great he worked
29 hours a day i mean this guy
works day and night he worked not the 24
he worked 24 plus at least five okay
this man is a worker and he's a
wonderful human being and when they try
it a guy like
biden that can't carry his jack strap
but biden when biden goes oh they should
have closed one week earlier
and here's a guy that said i made a
mistake when i banned china and that
nothing's gonna happen
it's so phony this politics is a very
phony business so i haven't been doing
it long i told one of the senators that
came in he came into my office sir
i've been doing this for 30 years
i've won many elections i've only lost
twice in my life
i've been a senator for a long time i
know what i'm doing sir i said yeah and
i've
done it for four years
and i've only won one election but it's
with the president of the united states
you know
remember when they said
i remember a certain man on television
that didn't like me too much
he said they put together the greatest
field ever assembled
the republicans remember 17 plus me
they put together the greatest field of
talent
ever assembled i hear trump wants to
come in
well he's not going to do it number one
number two if he does he's just doing it
for fun
and he'll be out by september and then
he'll go about leading his life
but he's not going to do it but we don't
really need him because this is the
greatest single
assemblage of talent ever assembled for
one party
the greatest talent he's ever seen and
then i did it
and just week after week one out two
three
four and then we've done changes
oh he said he can't do it because he
doesn't have any experience but i
actually do on the other side
i contributed to politics i always found
it very interesting so in a certain way
i had a lot of experience probably
maybe i had too much experience that's
why i can tell you about aoc check out
the two
million dollars please check it out
check it out
check out omar check out omar get to
that great writer he should get oh
so the new york times won all these
pulitzer prizes right i was going to
tell you before
all these pulitzer prizes these people
and they all got it wrong right they got
for russia russia
russia we give the public surprise i
won't use names
i won't use names but we give the
pulitzer prize to the new york times
they got it wrong
we give the pulitzer prize to the
washington post
and all of these real sleaze bags i have
to be honest with you very dishonest
people
very dishonest i call it the amazon i
call it the amazon washington post he
uses that as his
lobbyist because he owns the washington
post he gets crap that other people
wouldn't get okay
that means it's a lobby it's a lobbyist
deal but they got
the prize right they got the pulitzer
prize all the guys that got it
right that really got it right they all
got it wrong totally wrong and they
should return the pulitzer prize
and pulitzer association the committee
should ask for those prizes back they
got it all wrong they were 100
wrong there was no collusion they
couldn't believe remember the day when
it was announced
after three years there is no collusion
i could have told them that on day one
they could have saved 48 million though
right they got the pulitzer and then you
take guys
so many so many solomons sarah carter
pangino how about then
[Music]
so many so talented guys how about
the great gentleman who wrote the witch
hunt
remember that that was the first right
you know i'm talking about it he's
fantastic all great
these people should have won the
pulitzer prize now i would say sean
hannity and lou dobbs and
laura tucker in all fairness tucker was
very good
[Applause]
tucker was great but these are all
people that got it right now they don't
do i guess the pulitzer prize for that
stuff but they probably should
but these guys all got it right and all
they did is get a lot of money because
they're very successful
and that's okay i guess but they should
give the pulitzer prize to the people
that got it right and they should
withdraw it
from all of those writers many of whom
are back there right now
all of those writers they should do that
so
just to finish up just to finish up
i want to just say that we have some
great congressmen here
i'd love you guys to come up here
because i just want to have you come up
would you come up
they deserve it
because you know i told them they're
busy guys and they're big warriors and
all that and
i told them i'm going to introduce you
right at the beginning be here and then
you could get out of here
they've been waiting now for an hour and
20 minutes come on up but just walk to
the end
shake their hand everybody sign a slip
that you're voting for them please
they've got no problem but you have
members of congress here
jim hagedorn tom emmer
pete stauber great hockey player
[Applause]
and hopefully your next u.s senator
who's a man who's done a fantastic job
run a great campaign jason lewis
[Applause]
and a candidate for congress michelle
fishbach who's supposed to be fantastic
and michelle has my complete and total
endorsement but jason you're in good
shape wow
you're in better shape than these uh
congressman james
by the way jason's fantastic and he's
doing a fantastic where's michelle
she there be careful it's not worth the
broken legs
look at her oh she's a warrior i can
tell
come on up
[Applause]
but thanks michelle and they have my
complete endorsement they're great
people they love your state they love
our country
so just in conclusion i want to say that
over the next four years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
we will make our medical supplies right
here in the united states
and you probably heard me today you know
it used to be puerto rico did tremendous
dollars in medical supplies and then
what happened they made a lot
they did a good job and obama biden
destroyed it they took away the
incentive all of the taxes
and they took away the incentive and
puerto rico went down a long way
we'll get some of that back to puerto
rico we'll get it back fast
take it away from china
they took it away and then people
automatically vote you know it's like a
habit well i vote for the democrat the
democrat was so bad to you
and how bad were the democrats to israel
we did jerusalem
right we broke up the iran deal right
[Applause]
and then they vote for a democrat it's
out of habit but i think the habits
we're breaking those habits very quickly
but we've helped puerto rico and we've
really helped if you look at what we've
done for
israel it's been it's been incredible
they say nobody nobody's done more
it's my honor but we'll hire more police
increased penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
which are a disaster
we'll appoint tough on crime prosecutors
we will nominate judges and justices who
interpret
the constitution as written
we will ensure equal justice for
citizens of every race color religion
and creed we will defend the dignity of
work
and the sanctity of life
and that's why the supreme court is so
important the next president
will get one two three or four supreme
court justices i had two
many presidents have had none they've
had none because they're there for a
long time
they tend to be appointed young they're
there for a long time
but the next one will have anywhere from
one to four think of that
that will totally change when you talk
about life when you talk about
second amendment when you talk about
things that are so important to you
you're going to be stuck for 40 years 35
years a long time
so this is going to be the most
important election in my opinion in the
history of our country you got to get it
because if you don't get it right we
will not have a country anymore
you're not going to have a country not
as we know it you won't have a country
anymore
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of these
ridiculous
horrible endless foreign wars countries
you've never heard of
home we will maintain america's
unrivaled
military might and we will ensure peace
through strength that's what we have now
peace restraint
remember what i told you about those
weapons we don't want to use ever
we don't want to use those weapons we
will end surprise medical billing
require price transparency january 1st
he doesn't even have to do anything yeah
i'll be so angry if he they'll say what
a job he's done on transparency can you
believe it and he won't even know what
transparency is
and it's complex and further reduce
health insurance premiums and
the cost of prescription drugs we've
done that already
we will strongly protect medicare and
social security
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon
and the united states will be the first
nation to land
an astronaut on mars
and we brought nasa back nasa when i got
in three and a half years ago
grass was growing through the cracks of
the runway
it was over it was closed it was nothing
now it's the number one space center in
the entire world by a factor of five
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
school
big deal we will teach our children to
love our country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust you know
you know that the democrat
national convention and the pledge of
allegiance had a caucus
two of them not one i heard the first
one i said oh they must have made a
mistake
they left under god out of the pledge of
allegiance
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah now they then said oh
well we didn't mean that
they meant it that's what they're going
to do
they're going to take god out of it just
like i was saying before
texas they don't want god they don't
want oil they don't want guns i don't
think they're going to do too well in
texas do you agree with that
i don't think they're going to do too
well in minnesota either
no but can you imagine you campaigning
and it doesn't play too well here but
can you imagine you're in texas and you
have a guy say
no oil no god
no guns oh i think i'm going to vote for
joe biden everybody
and then they say texas is in play it's
a very close
i have a friend in texas he said i think
you're winning by 15 points these people
are crazy
texas is in play they don't want to let
you have oil
think of it it's unbelievable texas is
in play
that's the fake news back there for
years they said it last time too
remember
you know texas when they say in play
that means it's too close to call
it's in play too close we've heard that
for a long time in play right
too close to call and they said it four
years ago texas is in play
this could be a terrible defeat losing
texas big state great state
this would be a tremendous defeat and
they said it about ohio too i think we
won by like nine points right
they said ohio is implied utah's in play
we won by a lot remember we beat a guy
named mcmuffin remember
he was going to take the state of utah
and then he was going to be able to
negotiate but that didn't work out he
came in third even hillary beat him
but they said texas is in play and i'd
go around telling my people damn it
texas doesn't play how to
every time i go they have 35 000 people
in the stadium
how could it possibly be a play they
shouldn't play my people would say i
don't think so
and we had a big texas rancher he was on
one of the shows he goes like you're
wearing a big beautiful hat i wish i
could wear those hats
it wouldn't work for me too well i don't
think it works for me right but it
worked for him and he said i don't know
too much about a lot
but i know one thing texas is not in
play and
this guy is going to win texas by a hell
of a lot of votes and that's what
happened that night
the night of the election
[Music]
the night of the election they called
the results i've been listening for six
months texas is so close we can't even
imagine it it's so close
this is big and they only call the
election
you know immediately if you win in a
landslide it's got to be like tremendous
and they said texas has closed the
stores
ladies and gentlemen donald trump has
won the state of texas they didn't even
say the polls were
closed they forgot to say the polls
which i wanted to say
i said how come i won i called my people
how could i have won
it was so close they called it before
they even said the doors were closed
and i heard from the governor of texas
great guy
greg abbott he said i said how we doing
compared to four years ago we did great
four years ago big
big win he said sir you're doing much
better but these guys keep saying
gets in play it's the same way that i'm
down nine points in minnesota
if i lose minnesota if i lose minnesota
jason i'm going to blame jason if i lose
the way we almost had it last time but
but we did the right thing we went to
michigan we won michigan first time in
many many years that michigan was one
it's a great state
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
and now you have a president who is
standing up for america
and standing up for minnesota
[Applause]
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers
and get out and vote and you know it
started today in minnesota
that's why i'm here it started today
go out of here you know what if the if
they're closed what the hell time is it
if they're close just stand in line like
you do you know people were here two
days ago trying to get in here it's
crazy
so do the same thing at the voting booth
please
[Music]
from saint paul to saint cloud
from rochester to duluth
and from minneapolis thank god we still
have minneapolis
to right here right here with all of you
great people
this state was pioneered by men and
women who braved the wilderness and the
winters
to build a better life for themselves
and for their families
they were tough and they were strong you
have good genes you know that right
you have good genes
[Applause]
a lot of it's about the genes isn't it
don't you believe the racehorse theory
you think we're so different you have
good genes in minnesota
they didn't have a lot of money they
didn't have a lot of luxury
but they had grit they had faith and
they had each other
that's what you have now you have each
other
[Music]
they were miners and lubberjacks
fishermen and farmers shipbuilders
and shopkeepers but they all had one
thing in common
they loved their families they loved
their countries
and they loved their god
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Applause]
and don't forget you went through years
where you weren't winning right years
and years
they closed down even with obama he
closed that iron ore i think he just
wanted to get even with you i don't know
he wasn't good it did not a good not a
guy we've knocked out about 84
of the things he did and you say i
wonder if he likes me
but you're getting used to winning and
you're going to see winning like you've
never seen before you had your best year
and you're going to win so much you've
heard this right i haven't said it in a
long time because we've been doing a lot
of winning
but you're going to win so much and
you're going to send jason
to the u.s senate
and you're going to keep winning and
winning and winning
you're going to win on trade you're
going to win on the military you're
going to win on everything you touch
minnesota is going to keep on winning
and you're going to get tired of winning
because minnesota doesn't want to win
all the time
your football team is going to win in
the big ten they say
right now we're going to keep on winning
in minnesota and you're going to get so
tired you're going to say
jason jason please please jason
go to the president see him in the oval
office stop him from winning we're
winning too much in minnesota
we can't stand it jason please please
jason
stop him from winning so much for
minnesota
we can't take it we're not used to it
because we went through years and years
and years where it was tough right
the mayor's know that that's why they
all endorsed the president
and i'm gonna look at jason i'm gonna
say no jason i'm sorry
the people of minnesota want to win
you're wrong jason they want to win
we're going to keep on going jason we're
going to keep on winning
and they're going to be happy as hell
jason
get jason and he's a great guy by the
way you have a senator that he's running
against i won't even mention names she
does
nothing nothing nobody even knows who
the hell she is
she goes to a meeting the other day
everyone's trying to figure out who is
she
this guy he even looks through a central
casting right
you know if you can get the look for
free that's good too right
but he's going to be fantastic
tremendous guy really successful and he
loves your state and he loves our
country so
jason please
knock on me
[Applause]
but you're going to win we're one
movement we're one people
one family and one glorious nation under
god
[Music]
and together with the incredible people
of minnesota
and you know what's going to be
operating at
strength because i owe it to these
incredible mayors that were so nice to
me that was such a nice thing and i
didn't politic you at all right i never
politicked you i said what how nice
and it's happening with so many other
things we have other endorsements from
police forces that i never asked and
all of a sudden they're coming from very
hostile territory so i just
appreciate you being here and i'm saying
this for you and i'm saying it for all
of you
okay thank you we will make america
wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you minnesota thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
young
cause you're in a new town there's no
need
to be
many ways
[Music]
it's funny
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Music]
what do
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by himself
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
boys
[Music]
i felt
ymca
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
pick yourself up
[Music]
ymca
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
for the band
[Music]
[Music]
music man
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
knows
[Music]
i feel sorry lying
[Music]
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
[Applause]
today
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
today
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
music man
m
now she's in me
always with me
turning dancing in my head
[Music]
[Music]
and you can hear me
when i say it softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
foreign
yes
[Music]
my
[Music]
you